wir waren heute dort auf diesen straßen
unterwegs wir haben von oben drauf
schauen können auch diese massen und
wenn man diese menschen demonstrieren
sieht wenn man hört wie sie für ihre
freiheit kämpfen dann kann man gar nicht
anders dann bekommt man gänsehaut das
geht einem so wahnsinnig nah und
wahrscheinlich auch weil es eben anders
ist als bei anderen protesten die ich
auch erlebt hat überall auf der welt wo
ist irgendwann dann gewalttätig wurde
oder zumindest steine geschmissen wurden
oder was auch immer das passiert hier
alles überhaupt nicht auch heute wieder
friedlich völlig friedliche proteste
hunderttausende die da marschiert sind
die dann gesagt haben er lukaschenko
gehört und einen gefangenen transporter
und man hat die gefangenen transporter
ein bisschen entfernt davon gesehen aber
die waren natürlich nicht für
lukaschenko dort sondern für die
demonstranten und sie hatten natürlich
muss sie angst haben dass sie wieder
verhaftet würden dann am ende haben sie
den platz verlassen und lukaschenko hat
sich martialisch gezeigt ist mit dem
hubschrauber eingetroffen bei seiner
residenz wird ein sturmgewehr
also es sind ganz ganz viele offene
fragen lieber aber ich sitze hier in
einem wohnzimmer einer dieser mutigen
frauen die in linz demonstrieren es ist
olesja sie spricht perfekt deutsch weil
die deutschlehrerin ist oder es ja du
bist als demonstranten in den
vergangenen tagen und wochen immer dort
gewesen
viele menschen wurden gefoltert brutal
zusammengeschlagen frauen teilweise
vergewaltigt woher nimmst du die mut in
not woher nehmt ihr alle den mut da
immer wieder zu demonstrieren
ja das ist ja das ist schwer
die waren ich war so erschüttert vom
ging von den bilder die wir gesehen
haben und all diesen schrecklichen
verhaftungen von blut wir konnten
einfach nicht zu hause bleiben
wir mussten ich musste immer auf die
straße ich musste meinen protest zeigen
natürlich können wir nicht gleiten lang
gültig bleiben so was gab es nie in
unserem land und wir konnten uns so was
auch nie vorstellen dass es so
natürlich ging dann wie auch die straßen
und protestierten woher aber nimmt ihr
den nun lukas schenkel hat sich jetzt
mit einem sturmgewehr gezeigt er hat
gesagt ab morgen will er möglicherweise
hier ein crackdown veranstalten du gehst
auf die straße und riskiert damit ihr am
ende auch ins gefängnis zu kommen und
möglicherweise brutal zugerichtet zu
werden wie andere von den berüchtigten
um uns bezahlt aber ich frage mich immer
sage mir immer wenn ich jetzt nicht
protestieren denn heißt dass diese leute
haben umsonst gestorben
sie wurden umsonst gefoltert und sie
haben ihr leben einfach so umsonst
vergoren und das kann ich nicht zulassen
das kann ich mir nicht verzeihen das
kann ich nicht vergessen
deswegen werde ich jeden tag
protestieren und wir schwören einander
jeden tag am hauptplatz
als sie abends zum hauptplatz gehen es
gibt unmengen bedeutet dort und wir
schwören einander dass wir am nächsten
tag wiederkommen wir skandieren jeden
tag jeden tag und das heißt dass wir es
uns schweren und des herrn wort halten
jetzt waren heute wieder hunderttausende
auf den straßen aber lukaschenko ist
immer noch präsident er ist immer noch
dort wann glaubst du ist der zeitpunkt
das ergehen wird oder wird er überhaupt
gehen wir haben die ersten tage sehr
gehofft darauf dass er wirklich geht
denn unserer denn die fälschung war so
offensichtliche die empörung die leute
der leute der vielen leute der mehrheit
war so offensichtlich dass wir fast
glaubten er kann's kartieren und
weggehen aber leider nicht und mit der
zeit haben wir verstanden dass es auch
nicht nie sein wird das erst aufgeben
das land nie aufgeben wird gilt es am
ende nur gewaltsam dann funktionieren
glaubst du dass das umschwenken könnte
hier in einer art bürgerkrieg von der
gewalt in wir niemand hören in der
niemand wissen die du gerade gesagt hast
wir sind sehr friedliche leute wir
beschädigen keine vitrinen oder noch
etwas wir hoffen ja ich persönlich mache
was ich kann ich gehe auf die straße und
ich hoffe nur auf das beste ich weiß
nicht was diesen mann beeinflussen kann
und er ist der letzte frage an dich in
dieser runde die bei uns in berlin
diskutiert setzen viele politiker oder
ausschließlich fast politiker und die
große frage ist was kann aus deiner
sicht europa jetzt tun braucht es
schärfere sanktionen
das ist eine zu komplizierte frage für
mich vielleicht wären die sanktionen
doch gut obwohl sie für die normalen für
die einfachen menschen etwas auf schönes
mitbringen
aber vielleicht würde durch eine
ökonomische krise die leute zu dem
gedanken bringen
das etwas zu ändern dass das ihr etwas
ändern müssen
denn heutzutage die hatten wir nicht in
allen betriebsmitarbeiter man leider
unterstützt die protestierenden
vielen dank für diese ausführung das was
du machst das was alle frauen dort und
alle menschen heute auf den straßen
getan haben glaube ich bewegt die
menschen in deutschland und ganz europa
und was ich sagen kann
bild wird weiter berichten und zeigen
passiert wenn's passiert wir führen da
die unter estland